rebecca it's so wonderful to see you uh
i'm so excited about the show when we
heard the announcement about clarice
because
you go back to thinking at the time you
watched silence on the lab so do you
remember when you watched it and your
reaction to it
yeah i actually it came out when i was
quite young
and i always knew about the film and i
was too scaredy cat to watch it i'm
i'm not good with like horrors i was
like i'm gonna be too scared i can't do
this i can't do this and i think
um you know one day i finally got the
like guts
yeah sat down and watched it and i was
like why did i wait so long to watch
this amazing film like i was so
captivated with it and i think
it's so intelligent and it's such a
thriller like obviously there's a horror
element to it but i think this is right
made me realize that there's a
difference between just horror and gore
and then thriller and so it i know i
fell in love with thrillers through this
movie yeah yeah that movie gets into
your head right you have to watch it
during the day
you can't sleep at night because it's
just a different type of thriller yeah
uh you know watching the film did you
have a chance to kind of go back to it
to watch how jody foster took it
took the character of clarice kind of
study her or did you just make it your
own
uh it's a bit of both i actually avoided
watching it because okay this i'm not
here to copycat
what jody foster did because i can't
because i'm not jodie foster i'm rebecca
brie
i i think the way that i homage jody is
in where she pitched the accent but also
in what she would have done i referenced
them
we have this amazing resource we have
this incredible book that thomas harris
wrote with all this information of the
inner workings of clarissa's
thinking and how she reacts in every
situation her
upbringing her backstory it's all there
it's an actor's dream
so all i have to do is reference the
book so i
i held off and i didn't watch it at all
because i actually didn't want to just
um i don't think it's right to copy
someone else's performance and i
wouldn't want to do that because this is
a continuation of the clarice story she
has to be able to continue to live
and breathe and to do that properly i
have to be able to make her my own
but i will admit two nights before we
were gonna start shooting the pilot i
finally sat down with my husband and we
had some pizza and a nice chianti
we went all right let's just watch it
once before we start
you indulged the movie and the whole
experience and it was just amazing it's
just
you know amazing to go wow these are
such huge shoes to fill
and i'm so honored to be the one
stepping up to the plate and
uh yeah it's it's just so exciting i can
feel the energy that you're actually
really enjoying this character i mean
what did it mean for you to take on
clarisse when you found out it was going
to be you
uh i mean the way can i tell you
i the way that i found out i got the
role was
alex and jenny called me alex because
obviously um i was waiting you know
biting my nails going oh my gosh what is
going to happen i wanted this role so
bad
and they called me and i answer the
phone and it's just dead silence
and then i hear hello clarice
i just i like literally i was on a
public street and i just screamed
everyone
[ __ ] you know but i was just like oh my
gosh
oh you're saying like at least to me
like i am going to be clarice this is
amazing
so uh yeah it's just so
it's just kind of mind-blowing to be
honest like um
i always dreamed of playing an iconic
role it's something i always kind of
envisioned i was always bringing to
myself you know i want to play an iconic
role i want to play an iconic role and
you know for me especially having read
the silence of the lambs the book
yeah i think you know i could
maybe say that clarice darling is one of
the best written female characters in
literary history but i would go as far
to say that she's one of the best
written characters in literary wow so
when we're talking about icons like
that's
that's massive so yeah
yeah it's it's beyond blessed i don't
even know
i don't even know how to describe it
yeah you can't think about it too much
because you'll get overwhelmed by it so
you just need to go
take this on and they're entrusting this
to me
and i'm just going to step up and dive
in and
um give it my absolute best and
you know it's going really well yeah i
love that in watching the trailer
there's a line that's describing clary's
you have a repetiti reputation of
hunting down
monsters which is very powerful because
she kind of i feel like clarice is able
to get into the mindsets of these serial
killers so what can we expect
for your character this season
well it's interesting you bring up the
monsters
because she does have a knack for
hunting down monsters in the physical
world but she also has a knack for
avoiding the monsters in her own psyche
so if you think of the events that
happen in the film
they're just the catalyst you know
they're just the catalyst for her to
actually
start to realize that her trauma that
she experienced through her upbringing
her father being shot
um getting sent to live with relatives
getting palmed off again to an orphanage
and
you know all those things that happened
to her in her childhood let alone
what's happened to her since being in
the fbi and just being a woman in this
you know man's world and then all of a
sudden boom it's like buffalo bill
happens and this bomb is dropped into
her life
and how how does it
how does a person continue on after that
like
he's parallel between catherine and
clarice catherine martin
you know and obviously katherine and
clarice were in different
situations down in that basement but
they were there together they were still
experiencing bill in capacity together
and it's really interesting to see the
parallel of how they both
are dealing or not dealing with that
experience
and so i love being able to play this
character we describe her
like she's this boiling pot right but
the lid's always on
and every now and then it threatens to
pop off because she's got this
this boiling water inside of her with
all her trauma that she's not dealt with
but then she continues to re-traumatize
herself
with her joy so it's a really
interesting journey for me going okay
i'm clarice styling and clarice is very
measured
and she's ambitious and she's not a
victim and she's fighting for other
people and she's going after
you know her job and like you know to
silence these lambs you know to take
care of the innocent
and yet she has you know the monsters in
her own soul kind of
undermining this you know what she wants
to be doing undermining the mission and
you know how but if she gives in to them
and starts to deal with them will she
fall apart completely and then she can't
do her job at all so which is the
what's the lesser evil here and so she's
kind of on this journey
throughout this first season going well
what have i got to deal with inside of
me
and is that going to make me a better
agent or is it going to
take me out of the field completely you
know so she's got
she's got a lot to deal with and a lot
of big decisions to make and a lot to
work through herself let alone what
she's doing out in the field
and yeah the very real um the murders
and the monsters and
you know the innocent that she needs to
protect out in the world
yeah and uh one of the things that we've
been talking about with my colleagues is
who is the best serial killer i don't
know if you watch a lot of thrillers but
i can't think of anyone at the level of
sir anthony
hopkins can you think of anyone else
that's a great serial killer in
tv and films i really can't honestly
in my head i can't he's so iconic in
this role
you